bonjour à tous dont rêvait bienvenue
dans votre 6h infos sur france 2
bonjour alix
serré
et louis vous êtes bien en direct
démonstration mais qui vois-je à
l'horizon
mais également une vessie
[Rires]
docteur balla du oui on est censé
doubler parce qu'à plus rien se salir
merci pour tout ce qu'ils ont fait pour
moi ballades et chansons en anglais
mais bac tu veux pas les riches dehors
les objets connectés parle donc en 2050
il semble tout à fait normal d'interagir
avec votre table ou votre lampe et
d'attendre surtout il arrive avoir l'air
intelligemment à l'aise sont éligibles
ans arrivera pas du tout un trip sous
acide contrairement à aujourd'hui nos
poubelles connectés quelles seront nos
déchets nos toilettes 2.0 pour nous
proposer chaque jour un bilan de santé
d'un polype
c'est comme on dit le matin on est tous
cas le matin oui c'est comme ça
tous
non pas du principe monde sait qu'elle
en attend
mais chromé matin
j'avais ce qu'a dit stéphane bern paris
devenue une ville poubelle
alors est pas le cheminot
non mais moi je suis inquiète tu très
inquiète parce que je sais pas comment
on va faire un pari sans stéphane bern
enfin moi j'ai les larmes qui montent
aux yeux comme à cette nouvelle comment
est ce qu'on va faire sans stéphane bern
pour nous dire que la ville est belle ce
qu'on n'arrive pas le à le voir nous
mêmes à la foire aux dindons de
varaignes il y a le concours
international du cri du dindon et c'est
exactement ce que vous imaginez
on oublie tout bas sur saint louis nord
savoir double août et ça peut avoir un
impact sur la sexualité google google ou
mais je ne vous donne qu'une information
arrêt que c'est très compliqué la
reproduction du dindon est extrêmement
compliqué qu'il ya des gens qui
inventent des machines pour loulou
exactement mais voilà et là il ya des
gens qui inventent des machines
spécialisées pour recueillir le sperme
se
recoucher et la lauréate du
international du cri du dardon et
kathryn
hâle est super jolie à lourdes
[Musique]
en deux mois de relation ces deux là se
sont transformés l'un l'autre pour être
aujourd'hui étonnamment décomplexée
le gonfle sur taille que le vent popoli
vanté comme ça
popol ventile
moi je vais te mettre à poil
moment quoi j'ai envie de faire un truc
pour vous soulevez ce qu'on faisait
laurent blanc à fabien barthez aimait
regarder
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Rires]
c'était pas très qu'ovide mais on est
vacciné tous les deux interdiction pour
les non vaccinés de sortir de chez eux
sauf pour faire les courses du sport ou
pour les soins médicaux
une mesure qui s'applique en autriche
dès aujourd'hui et pour au moins dix
jours objectif limiter la propagation du
coronavirus
l'incident chez les personnes vaccinées
est en baisse mais elle continue
d'augmenter de manière exponentielle
chez les personnes non vaccinées
actuellement l'incidence chez les
personnes non vaccinées pour les 18 59
ans est supérieur à 1700 toute personne
en infraction devra s'acquitter d'une
amende de 500 euros
1450 euros en cas de refus de contrôle
des amendes pouvant monter jusqu'à 3600
euros pour les commerçants qui ne
contrôleraient pas les certificats de
vaccination dans un pays qui compte 8,9
millions d'habitants où seuls 65% de la
population est vaccinée le gouvernement
veut accélérer à vienne voilà vous pied
mais d'économie une maison close offre
30 minutes de sexe au nouveau vacciner
c'est une très bonne ttc pour inciter
ses pour la cité on peut donc dire qu en
autriche ils ont mis en place un système
de pass sanitaires
à genève c'est très sérieux un club olé
olé offre une sélection gratuite à
chaque personne vaccinée de moins de
trois jours offre valable jusqu'au 30
novembre sur présentation d'un
justificatif
c'est très sérieux visiblement
l'initiative de ce sex club de genève
porte ses fruits
le polémiste français eric zemmour
annonce sa venue à genève le 24 novembre
fameuse théorie du gland remplacement
pas de suite à la cour de versailles
madame marie antoinette c'est possible
de manger avec les mains tout à fait
alors surtout qu' on est peut-être à
versailles mais on est dans l'intimité
de la reine donc raison plus pour pourri
pour y mettre les doigts
et non doucement pas les dents
en plus je me suis gratier
ses salariés rigaux dans l'actualité on
parle d'une technique de contraception
masculine définitif qui rencontrent de
plus en plus ce succès mais qui fait
peur la vasectomie et oui car dit comme
ça marina c'est vrai que la vasectomie
bien ça nous fait peur à nous les
messieurs que des cons bien d'autres
choses qui vous font peur mais dès qu'on
touche aux bijoux de famille pas
forcément on craint le pire c'est une
attaque gratuite
popol
on se ressemble j'ai trouvé je me suis
rarement qui
se sont voilà quand on va en est mais on
est bien dans quoi
douze minutes pour un record du monde
parfaitement alignés dans la cour de
l'académie militaire douze mille
musiciens vénézuéliens interprète la
marche slave de tchaïkovski
au milieu de cette foule 260
observateurs vérifie que tous les
musiciens jouent avec leurs propres
instruments au moins cinq minutes pour
que le record puisse être validé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]